he venido a contarles sobre un tema muy
difícil
tan difícil que incluso nuestras mentes
trabajan en muchos momentos del si
quieres estar en esto
se puede hablar de
todos tenemos miedo
tenemos miedo de la oscuridad tenemos
miedo a las alturas tenemos miedo a la
soledad tenemos miedo a los gases
pequeños
cuando yo de que ellos saben a quién le
tenía miedo
estaba con un cuarto quinto grado de
primaria cuando aprendí que la tierra se
movía a través del universo a una gran
velocidad
y en un momento me puse a pensar qué
pasaría si la tierra de repente se
detiene
como no haya de cuenta pregunté a mi
hermano
y como todos los mayores en el espacio
y saben qué
[Música]
no me aterra
pero vuelo pidieron más estudios
mantenimientos crecimiento y pues el
medio se fue haciendo tan increíble
todos los momentos
tenemos miedo al los venados y lo
vivimos de diferentes maneras
porque de todas maneras pues somos
humanos y spain a toda nuestra
naturaleza es tener bien
como todo ser humanos nosotros nos
mantenemos en manos de constante
crecimiento
y aprendizaje
y crecemos y nuestros valores siempre
dejamos a vivir con ellos en el mejor de
los casos
con peros
en la venta de la motivación al y
político del fraude con tú eres el único
ángulo real en tu camino a una vida
plena
esa frase suena muy importante pero a mí
me trae a la mente con la frase
igual de importante pero totalmente
opuesta que muchos de nosotros vamos a
mantener la vida
no puedo
al usar esa frase si ustedes analizan
bien que queremos decir al pueblo
estamos diciendo tengo miedo a fracasar
tengo miedo a no completar la tarea
tengo miedo al quién análisis y no puedo
completar
cuando ya tenía 16 años estaba en casa
de los amigos
y en ese momento se encontraba señor
realizando unos trabajos de soldadura
y un monto de curiosos me acerqué a este
señor trabajador de la empresa con félix
abrazo a todos
luego buscando del señor hizo una pausa
en su trabajo y amanecer queriendo noche
para preguntarle
en el total
mientras yo también
voy a leer
si yo puedo
también puedes
y les cuento que lo quería soltar nunca
aprendí a hacer portones niveles
elementales pero esas palabras
el escritor el escritor los pensamientos
de terminar tu vida
los pensamientos y cambiará su vida
después ya que
cambié los pensamientos y cambiará su
vida
así que cambiemos nuestros pensamientos
después tenemos a toda nuestra tarea con
una mente positiva y un gran yo vuelvo
[Música]
el activista siempre parece imposible
hasta que sea
porque no importa cuándo
después de completar
lo importante es el final del día la
satisfacción más grande que van a sentir
pasión
no importan ciertos días en cuanto a la
importación deporte como pasatiempo
zidane
le dará una de sus tareas
vas a completar todas las medidas y
objetivos en la vida
así que a partir de este momento
vamos a mostrar
toda la forma en que hacemos nuestras
tareas en esta vida y nos vamos a
apretar con una actitud positiva
y si lo hacemos así algún día se
presentará también en tu vida y quiero
amanecer
esto es imposible
eso no se puede hacer
sabes que levantarlo
qué bien yo voy a ser el primero en
hacerlo muchas gracias